our next two presenters bit of one of
those Oscar odd couples
he's the brooding handsome star of one
of this year's top dramas and he's the
brooding handsome star of one of this
year's top dramas please welcome Josh
Brolin and James McAvoy
there's no place like home you're gonna
need a bigger boat
frankly my dear I don't give a damn
we'll always have Paris
is it safe leave the gun take the
cannoli this is fun what's that from
no I'm just saying it's fun seeing lanes
from some of the best scripts ever
written based on material previously
produced or published with my brains and
your looks we could go places never a
truer word spoken Joshua thank you god
that was mine Nicholson that was one of
the worst Nicholson's ever done in the
history I'm sorry man I'll buy a drink
afterwards okay no I apologize
anyway the nominees for Best Screenplay
based on material previously produced or
published are
Christopher Hampton for atonement based
on the novel by Ian McEwan Sarah Polley
for away from her based on the short
story the bear came over the mountain by
Alice Munro
Ronald Harwood the diving bell and the
butterfly based on the book by Jean
Dominique bogey joel coen and Ethan Coen
for No Country for Old Men based on the
novel by Cormac McCarthy Paul Thomas
Anderson for there will be blood based
on oil by Upton Sinclair all right here
we go and the Oscar goes to Joel Coen
and Ethan Coen oh man including their
nominations this year for directing and
Best Picture this is the sixth
nomination and second Academy Award for
Joel and Ethan Coen they took home their
first Oscar for writing the original
screenplay of Fargo
ah thank you very much for this thank
you Scott Rudin for bringing us this
novel and giving us the opportunity to
make the movie I think whatever success
we've had in this area has been entirely
attributable to how selective we are
we've only adapted homer and Cormac
MacCarthy so thank you we thank you very
much